stimulation individuelle et sans
concertation avéré c'est le sens de
cette ré moment que de prendre la
garantie qu avant d'élaborer ce décret
sur le suivi des indicateurs et de leurs
objectifs nous puissions consulter
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
représentatives
merci monsieur jumelles donc
l'amendement pardon série d'amendements
identiques le 50 qui le public
monsieur cherpion oui une demande de
scrutin public peut-être donc à la
demande du groupe l'est républicain
demandes de scrutins publics sur
l'amendement 50 le scrutin est annoncée
dans l'enceinte de l'assemblée nationale
bien monsieur cherpion vous avez la
présidente
oui cet amendement finalement est un
amendement d'appel puisqu'en fait il
vise à substituer ou décret le décret
pris en conseil d'état
mes sujets en fait est plus vaste nous
avons déposé sur ce texte des
amendements de façon à ce que le la
place du décret à la place j'ai créé ce
soit la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale qui interviennent de
façon à ce que les parlementaires
puissent se prononcer ces amendements
avaient été jugés recevables en
commission il recevable en séance je ne
vais pas revenir sur ce sujet mais le
conseil d'état vous adresser un carton
jaune comme ceux concernant pardon des
29 ordonnance soulignant je cite le fait
pour le lycée at her de s'en remettre à
des ordonnances pour la définition des
éléments structurants du nouveau système
de retraites fait perdre la visibilité
d'ensemble qui est nécessaire à
l'appréciation des conséquences de la
réforme et partant de sa
constitutionnalité
et sur ces points essentiels en fait
vous en avez décrit reporte sur quatorze
articles et ça c'est quand même pas
rêver beaucoup la fixation de par
exemple du nombre de points etc
mais permettez-moi de vous rappeler que
l'article 34 de la constitution dispose
que le loi fixe les règles concernant
l'assiette le taux et les modalités de
recouvrement des impositions de toute
nature permettez moi aussi de vous
rappeler que l'article 34 dispose que
les lois de financement de la sécurité
sociale déterminée
conditions générales de son équilibre
financier et compte tenu de leurs
prévisions de recettes fixe ses
objectifs de dépenses dans les
conditions et sous les réserves prévues
par une loi organique
permettez moi enfin de vous souligner
que l'article l aux 100 aux tirs et 3 du
code de la sécurité sociale disposent
que la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale fixe les charges prévisionnelles
des organismes concourant au régime
obligatoire des régimes de base et
modifie les règles relatives aux
cotisations et contributions affective
aux régimes obligatoires de base ou aux
organismes concourant à leur financement
ou regarder 21 renvoi au décret je ne
suis pas exhaustif il est clair que
votre objectif est de seulement de
contourner le parlement mais plus encore
de le déposséder de ses pouvoirs au
mépris des règles constitutionnelles et
organique faisant peser sur ce texte
un risque juridique majeure merci
monsieur cherpion le 257 qui le défend
chez les républicains
le 257 monsieur bazin oui mais merci
mais à la présente monsieur le ministre
là on est sur un sujet majeur avec un
vrai risque d'inconstitutionnalité
et je crois qu'il faut comme l'a
démontré mon excellemment mon collègue
et voisin lorrain gérard cherpion
on a un vrai sujet de fond vous ne
pouvez pas rester sur les modalités que
vous avez défini puisque notre
constitution dit vous invite à faire le
contraire et il faut absolument passer
par le plfss sur ce sur ses modalités là
c'est vraiment un enjeu essentiel sinon
vous risquez vraiment
l'inconstitutionnalité on est là pour
vous aider
on vous le dis très clairement et donc
on vous invite maintenant à modifier
votre texte sur ce sujet merci monsieur
bazin le 2545
monsieur
jeux valve ou peut-être monsieur janicot
monsieur janicot oui c'est un amendement
extrêmement importants comme vient de le
dire notre collègue bazin dans la mesure
où toutes les discussions que nous avons
depuis lundi dernier sur l'article un
visa une chose c'est qu'on puisse
dissiper le brouillard épais qui qui
entoure les objectifs généraux de votre
réforme du système de retraite et pas
simplement pour que le parlement soit
éclairé et on a vu toutes les réserves
du conseil d'état mais tout simplement
le parlement étant éclairé que les
français ils comprennent quelque chose
parce que les questions sont assez
basiques pour nos concitoyens
à quel moment je pourrais partir en
retraite avec quels montants de pension
et dans quelles conditions et sur toutes
ces questions là que l'on prenne tous
vos objectifs généraux que nous avons
décortiqué la lisibilité la garantie du
maintien de vie la question de la
liberté de choix
vous êtes en difficulté aujourd'hui pour
apporter des réponses précises
donc ce brouillard épais il faut
effectivement le dissiper et c'est
pourquoi le conseil d'état a un rôle
majeur à jouer dans l'aide support qu'il
peut être apportée au gouvernement sur
l'élaboration d'un certain nombre
d'indicateurs de suivi
même si pour la liberté de choix
j'attends de savoir que sera un
indicateur de suivi ça va être quand
même relativement compliquées à mettre
au point mais au regard des réserves et
de l'avis du conseil d'état extrêmement
sévère sur l'étude d'impact indigente
sur le fait que beaucoup de paramètres
vont évoluer jusqu'au dernier moment ce
choix là pour les français de savoir à
quel moment ils pourront partir à la
retraite sans doute qu'avec l'évolution
des paramètres de l'âge des équilibres
la question de la valeur du point
aujourd'hui encore beaucoup
d'incertitudes nous aurons effectivement
des difficultés majeures pour savoir
exactement quand les français pourront
partir à la retraite merci monsieur juin
nicole 22700 de n'est pas défendu
le 24 1640 n'est pas défendu le
sous-amendement 40 2117 monsieur je mêle
monsieur brunel il est défendu le
sous-amendement il est défendu bien
alors nous en avons terminé que cette
discussion commune monsieur le
rapporteur sur l'ensemble de ses
amendements et sous-amendement merci
madame la présidente
quelques éléments de précisions sur la
définition de ces de ces indicateurs qui
reprend non comme aujourd'hui les
différents éléments de suivi dont sont
dotés le comique le le corps ou le
comité de suivi des retraites il faut
savoir que ces indicateurs déjà leur
définition et pour répondre à notre
collègue bazin relève du niveau
réglementaire et pas de la loi donc je
ne vois pas où est le le risque
constitutionnel deuxièmement il pour
répondre ce que je n'ai pas pu répondre
tout à l'heure notre collègue ballot
mais ça reprend cette question à travers
ses différents articles
ces indicateurs existent déjà
aujourd'hui ils seront actualisées et
ils ont été définies par décret simple
suite à la loi de 2014 donc dans
quelques-uns la durée moyenne de
versement de pensions sur 25 ans le
niveau de vie de retraite des retraités
par rapport à la population
il existe aujourd'hui ils vont rester
ils vont être actualisée par décret bien
entendu après et par décret simple n'y a
pas besoin d'y associer le conseil le
conseil d'état et je vous renvoie sur
l'ensemble de ces indicateurs au décret
simple numéro 2000 14-6 154 du 20 juin
2014 relatif au comité de suivi des
retraites dans lequel il y à ccc
indicateurs ailleurs sur l'un des tout
premiers et aux amendements le 26 732
qui pointait le fait qu'il ya un
objectif de réinstaurer un véritable
dialogue social autour de la création de
ces de ces indicateurs
jusqu'à présent il n'y avait pas on va
pas utiliser le mot réinstaurer puisque
jusqu'à présent il n'y avait pas de
dialogue social autour de la création de
ces indicateurs qui effectivement été
créée par
voie de décret par contre il
appartiendra peut-être au gouvernement
lorsqu'il y aura la construction de
flammes la mise à jour de ces
indicateurs par voie d'écrit d'y
associer
je pense que c'est souhaitable
l'ensemble des partenaires des
partenaires sociaux mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que c'est le nouveau système
universel qui met en place une
gouvernance paritaire et qui avance
associer davantage les partenaires
sociaux par rapport à ce que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui aussi sur
l'ensemble de ses amendements et
sous-amendement ce sera une demande de
retrait ou à défaut un avis défavorable
je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre national la présidente en bon
mesdames messieurs député d'abord je
voudrais vous dire je suis extrêmement
touché gouvernement extrêmement touchée
de la sollicitude du député thibeault
vase 1 et 2 du groupe est républicain
dans sa volonté de vouloir aider le
gouvernement
je ne doute pas que ce soit une volonté
républicaine de qui est exprimée ici ou
quoi que
allez peut-être teintée d'une certaine
malice mais mais je ne voudrais pas
voilà mais ceci étant je pense qu'elle
est bien exprimer et je voudrais je
voulais juste en faire un accusé de
réception positif à la fois pour revenir
sur le fond si vous voulez bien monsieur
le député monsieur le député aussi
gérard cherpion qui nous a interpellés
sur les ordonnances
je vais vous dire monsieur le député
thibeault voisins vous savez le conseil
d'état s'est exprimé mais s'est exprimé
aussi sur ce décret et qu'est ce qu'il a
dit est là bas du tout considéré que
décret qui fixe ces indicateurs devait
passer entre ses mains sinon comme vous
l'avez vu il aurait il n'aurait pas
manqué d'exprimer ce qui aurait été
important pour lui juridiquement et puis
quand même par rapport à un certain
nombre d'autres remarques préalables qui
ont pu être faites sur ce texte
je l'avais dit aux députés pierre
d'arrivée je crois avant-hier donc je
leur dis bien volontiers de ce côté-là
de l'hémicycle le texte initial qui a
été repris par le gouvernement c'est
celui du conseil d'état c'est bien parce
qu on a tenu compte des conseils du
conseil d'état que nous
un texte qui est solide juridiquement
alors il m'a été objecté avant-hier je
crois où il ya trois-quatre jours par
demont à la présidente tu finis pas pu
savoir sur le fond quel jour nous sommes
mais il m'a été objecter que oui mais
alors là pour les enseignants les
enseignants chercheurs mais nous
assumons le gouvernement assume le la
décision politique
l'engagement politique qu'il prend est
le signe le signal fort qui envoie aux
enseignants et aux enseignants
chercheurs tout simplement parce que les
concertations ont déjà débuté entre jean
michel blanquer ray les enseignants
qu'un certain nombre de lignes
budgétaires très significatives ont déjà
été libérés pour 2021 et que nous
construisons effectivement la nouvelle
le nouveau parcours professionnel des
enseignants en tenant compte d'une
rémunération qui doit être réactualisé
revisité et qui garantira et qui
garantira un niveau de retraite pour les
enseignants équivalent à celui de
l'ensemble des fonctionnaires de
catégorie a donc voilà il faut être pour
soi très très clair sur le fait que le
conseil d'état joue son rôle de conseil
juridique du gouvernement et le
gouvernement est à l'écouté des retours
du conseil d'état il peut aussi je pense
que vous en seriez d'accord puisque vous
êtes un sur le fond un mouvement de
gouvernement on peut que se féliciter
que le gouvernement aussi soit en
situation de prendre des décisions
politiques fortes et qui veulent les
inscrire dans la loi et qu'ils en
assument tout l'engagement sur les
autres aspects qui ont été éclairés
parce que moi j'entends que le député
boris vallot souhaitait et éclairé
madame la présidente sur un certain
nombre d'indicateurs est un petit peu la
difficulté quand on a parfois quand on
débat sur ce texte et on a
des questions qui sont sans aucun doute
légitime mais dont il apparaît que elles
n'ont visiblement pas fait l'objet d'un
travail extrêmement pointus lors de
l'examen des projets de lois précédent
et donc le rapporteur général a très
bien expliqué qu' il y avait déjà ce
tome deux indicateurs de suivi qui
existait que il avait l'intérêt qu'il
pourrait d'ailleurs évolué j'entends
monsieur le député vous avez des
inquiétudes sur le fait que ce soit des
indicateurs qui soit intéressant et
partager avec les partenaires sociaux
bas ils seront partagés avec les
partenaires sociaux
et donc il sera donc intéressant voilà
madame la présidente pourquoi j'ai un
avis défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre un bien donc
monsieur monsieur jacob vous avez la
parole merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre je voudrais revenir
sur les les arguments qui ont été
évoqués par mais mes deux collègues
précédemment sur le lot rist le risque
d'inconstitutionnalité sur le rapporteur
vont tenter d'y répondre mais le risque
est bien est bien réel quand on reprend
les attendus du conseil d'état on a à la
fois un risque sur le plan juridique
et puis un vrai sujet politique le
risque sur le plan juridique c'est
lorsqu'on s'appuie sur l'article 34 de
la constitution comme ça a été rappelé
tout à l'heure qui doit la loi doit
fixer l'assiette les taux et les
modalités de financement or on voit bien
qu'il ya une incertitude sur tous ces
points puisque vous avez suspendu la la
mesure de financement sur l'âge pivot à
la conférence de financement donc on ne
sait pas aujourd'hui
l'assiette globale qui sera retenue on
ne connaît pas les taux puisque voulait
renvoyer effectivement un décret donc le
risque juridique il est d'une évidence
totale et le risque sur le plan
politique et démocratique
il existe tout autant c'est à dire on
travaille sur un projet de réforme des
retraites sur un budget qui globalement
représente plus de 300 milliards 300 320
milliards je crois sans un débat du
financement ici au parlement
et on nous dit mais c'est pas grave
voter le texte tel qu'il est là le
financement sont occupera après avouez
quand même qu'il y à là non seulement
une incertitude mais des vrais risques à
tous les niveaux et le risque
démocratique où il a été évoqué tout à
l'heure je crois que c'était vous
monsieur le ministre qui parlait à la
fois de la démocratie représentative la
démocratie sociale fayat qu'une
démocratie est la démocratie elle est
incarnée par les représentants du peuple
et les représentants du peuple
aujourd'hui sont complètement bafouée et
méprisée dans la mesure où ils ne vont
pas voter le budget et le financement de
ce système de retraite qui pousse sur
320 milliards non on ne le vote pas
puisque ça passera par ordonnance ou ce
sera reportée après la conférence des
présidents
c'est ce qui à la conférence de
financement pardon excusez le lapsus
si j'étais après la conférence des
présidents se serait pas grave on le
verra demain mais ça n'est pas le cas ce
n'est pas ce qui est prévu c'est prévu
après la conférence de financement et
donc peut-être que le sénat aura à se
prononcer dessus on verra mais pour ce
qui est de l'assemblée on ne pourra pas
le faire et donc ce ce sujet
d'inconstitutionnalité il est réel et
vous ne vous n'y avez pas répondu
si monsieur jacob madame limon merci
madame la présidente
plusieurs sujets ont été abordés sur ces
amendements ou des sous-amendements je
vais en retenir deux les ordonnances
tout d'abord mais nous nous estimons
qu'elles sont préférables au décret
parce qu'elle revienne devant le
parlement et prennent le temps dans la
réflexion réflexion concernant la
transition
nous sommes là pour écrire de cadre
général de la loi ensuite les bleus
la place des partenaires sociaux nous
souhaitons effectivement et ça n'existe
pas aujourd'hui une instance
indépendante
elle apportera son expertise à la cn est
rude dans le cadre du pilotage financier
en effet la mise en place d'un comité
d'experts aura pour mission d'orienter
et d'évaluer le pilotage financier du
système sans pour autant se substituer
aux décideurs
donc nous ça nous va bien voilà je vous
remercie
merci madame ou monsieur contre elle moi
je trouve que le débat qu'on a la montre
qu' il est il est vraiment plus que
nécessaire plusieurs choses par rapport
à ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure à la
question posée au ministre sur les
indicateurs de suivi de ces jeux beat
objectif pardon monsieur le ministre on
a bien entendu à renvoyer à l'article 55
bons premiers intéressés que on parle
d'indicateurs de suivi de ces objectifs
pour contribuer au pilotage du système
universel de retraite
or vous renvoyer à un article ne parle
que du pilotage financier et que je
sache le pilotage du système de
retraites peut pas en théorie en tout
cas être seulement dépendant du pilotage
financier
et si en réalité il est c'est parce que
vous admettez vous même que
contrairement à ce qui se passe
maintenant la question ne sera plus à la
priorité des prestations définies mais à
la priorité de l' équilibre du système
financier
en vertu de l'équipe financier sur cinq
ans que vous mettez comme condition plus
le fait de ne pas augmenter les
cotisations donc ça dit bien que la
liberté du conseil national du comité
national qui décidera a théoriquement de
certaines choses par rapport aux dreads
sera conditionnée uniquement par l'
équilibre comptable ça ne peut pas être
plus mieux dit que par rapport à la
réponse que vous avez fait et quant à la
question de monsieur jacob je la trouve
excellente sur cette question dans deux
problématiques de constitutionnalité
alors j'entends notre collègue qui dit
mais les ordonnances reviendront au à
l'assemblée m'enfin on va voter une loi
dont par ordonnance un certain nombre de
conditions sur la transition
justement entre le système actuel est le
futur système qui est le sujet même de
la conférence de financement ne sera
connue qu'après qu'on ait voté la loi
c'est quelque chose d'aberrant et c'est
bien pour ça d'ailleurs que nous vous
demandons au lieu 200 arrêts faire
passer des rumeurs comme quoi le conseil
des ministres de mercredi
elle partira sur le 49-3 j'aimerais bien
d'ailleurs avoir une réponse là dessus
monsieur ministre puisque on entend ça
depuis tout à l'heure on pourrait avoir
une réponse du gouvernement
est ce que c'est vrai ou pas est ce que
c'est vrai ou pas cette histoire ça
bruisse de partout donc je vous dis
qu'au lieu de faire ce genre de
déclaration qui est un déclaration de
chantage
vous feriez mieux de renvoyer tout vote
de cette loi après la conférence de
financement ça serait raisonnable
endurer ça nous mettrait cette semaine
de débats et ça serait raisonnable par
rapport à la constitutionnalité de la
loi que vous voulez nous imposer merci
monsieur coquerel monsieur vélo d'abord
rappeler à mes collègues que j'adore qui
disait qu'elle préférait les les écrits
aux ordonnances qu'il y en a un qui
relèvent de l'article 37
les ordonnances les ordonnances au
kremlin qui relève de l'article 37 et
l'autre de l'article 34 de la
constitution donc ça n'a rigoureusement
rien à voir c'est le domaine législatif
et le domaine réglementaire mais vous ne
serez pas déçus parce que vous aurez les
deux vous aurez et 30 et 27 ordonnance
et 110 et 110 décret je voudrais
puisqu'il ya un certain nombre
d'indicateurs qui existait s'agit dans
ce qu'on voyait pas avant des exemples
d'un indicateur de suivi de l'objectif
de liberté de choix ça m'intéresserait
d'avoir un exemple concret ou alors un
indicateur de suivi de l'objectif de
lisibilité
ça aussi ça m'intéresserait de voir ce
qu'il ya comme comme comme élément est
en effet il est plutôt intéressant
d'avoir l'avis du conseil d'état parce
que c'est quand même l'avis du conseil
d'état qui vous a rappelé quand même à
ce que devait être une étude une étude
d'impact et il a considéré que ce
n'était pas au niveau donc on a besoin
de cela par ailleurs l'engagement pris
quai et volt évoqué tout à leurs
vis-à-vis des enseignants s'il vaut ce
que valent et l'engagement des ministres
et du président de la république
s'agissant des agriculteurs à la
retraite on peut douter de cette parole
je rappelle juste que monsieur castetner
disait par exemple au moment où il avait
été fait obstacle à au sénat à la
proposition de loi qui avait été votée
ici à l'assemblée nationale est né me
disais si le gouvernement a déposé un
amendement et demander le vote bloqué ce
n'est pas vous demander de renoncer à ce
texte ou à vous faire hurler mais a
reporté son entrée en vigueur au 1er
janvier 2020 et par ailleurs madame
busin disait vous pouvez compter sur moi
et sur le commissaire jean paul delevoye
pour que cette question des retraites
agricoles sont pleinement prises en
compte lors de la réforme des retraites
il faut dire que ni l'un ni l'autre ne
sont là aujourd'hui pour tenir cette
parole mais enfin
on a un peu de mal à croire à vos
engagements si monsieur vélo monsieur
jumelles écoutez tout d'un coup j'ai été
rajeunie mais boris vallée vient de dire
j'avais l'impression d'assister à un
cours de droit constitutionnel de
première année où notre collègue nous
faisait bakou tehran on on avait le
choix entre les ordonnances et le décret
soyez satisfait qu'on ait eu recours aux
ordonnances m'enfin c'est pas comme ça
que ça marche que la guerre il ya des
domaines qui relèvent du pouvoir
législatif article 37 et il ya des
domaines qui relèvent du poids
réglementaire article 37 ont fait pas ce
qu'on veut de la constitution la bricole
pas comme on veut
par contre il est clair que lorsqu'on a
recours 29 fois de suite aux ordonnances
online le signal du respect que nous
avons pour le parlement mais moi je ne
résiste pas au plaisir de vous redire ce
que le conseil d'état a dit pas ce que
parce que c'est ce qui nous occupe
depuis tout à l'heure
les projections financières ne sont pas
sincère et crédible
les saisines d'organisation concerné
pourra ville ont été trop tardivement
les délais des analyses du conseil
d'état sont trop courts pour assurer la
sécurité juridique du texte une critique
par ailleurs le conseil d'état fait une
critique toulon du recours systématiser
aux ordonnances pour un domaine aussi
complexe et dans un temps imparti aussi
coup enfin fermez le ban donc si en plus
de ça ils disent nos débats nos discours
et qu'on leur dit ben coudon
on a beaucoup hésité savoir si on allait
recourir au décret ou aux ordonnances et
puis comme on a voulu vous faire plaisir
on a choisi d ordonnancement fin sur
quelle planète juridique êtes-vous je ne
sais pas encore je mais je vais me
replonger dans mes cours de droit
première année merci monsieur jumelles
bien alors mes chers collègues nous
commençons par le scrutin public sur les
amendements 25 1732 identique de
monsieur
jumelles et les membres de son groupe
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici les résultats du scrutin votent
ensemble de exprimé 92 majorité 47 pour
15 contre 77 l'assemblée n'a pas adopté
alors nous allons maintenant vers les
amendements identiques qui ont fait
l'objet de sous-amendements donc le
sous-amendement de monsieur lachaud le
42 1491 qui est pour et qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté le sous amendement
défendu par monsieur coquerel 42 1492
qui et pour qui et contre il n'est pas
adopté je mets aux voix les amendements
identiques 59 et suivant qui n'ont pas
été sous-amendé de monsieur défendu par
monsieur d'or qui est pour et qui est
contre
ils ne sont pas adopté le 30 5712 est
identique du groupe gdr qui fait l'objet
d'une demande de scrutin public
le scrutin est ouvert le scrutin est
clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votants 95
exprimé 90 majorité 46 pour 18 contre 72
l'assemblée n'a pas adopté les
amendements identiques 50 et suivant qui
font l'objet d' un sous-amendement que
je mets déjà aux voix main levée à
monsieur jumelles le sous-amendement 40
2117 qui et pour qui et contre il n'est
pas adopté donc scrutin public sur les
amendements identiques 50 défendu par
monsieur cherpion
est identique le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votants 96
exprimé 94 majorité 48 pour 23 contre 71
l'assemblée n'a pas adopté une série
d'amendements identiques le 11 1375 de
monsieur brun monsieur d'or vous avez la
parole oui merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre le terme d'
universelle est devenu véritablement je
sais votre totem mais je crois qu'il est
devenu inadapté il adapté tant il ya des
exceptions qui se sont accumulés petit à
petit des spécificités qui ont donc été
acceptée et qui font donc que le terme
d' universelle ne correspond plus du
tout à la réalité de votre projet comme
nous n'iront certainement pas ou
probablement avec des difficultés à
l'article 4 je voudrais profiter de cet
amendement pour vous poser une question
sur l'avenir de des médecins libéraux
les médecins libéraux ont une caisse
autonome monsieur le ministre
s'il vous plaît monsieur le ministre on
en a parlé lors de la commission
spéciale déjà mais je voudrais
aujourd'hui à pouvoir évoquer ce sujet
ils ont une caisse autonome qui
fonctionne bien qui est en autogestion
ils n'ont rien demandé à personne ni au
gouvernement ni à quiconque et le on
souhaitait y compris lors de de votre
prédécesseur monsieur de le voir de dire
garde dont notre caisse
nous sommes en dehors du système
universel alors moi je voudrais vous
dire que le ciel leur est tombé sur la
tête lorsqu'ils ont fait leurs comptes
ce qu'on appelle la caisse autonome de
retraite des médecins libéraux à savoir
quand à un niveau de 3 passes détroits
passent leur pension sera réduite
d'exactement de 26 7%
c'est à dire largement en dessous de ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
donc les futurs médecins libéraux auront
des petites retraites et voulait pousser
mais vraiment on les pousse à faire de
la capitalisation
car s'ils veulent avoir une retraite
correcte à haut niveau d'aujourd'hui il
faudra obligatoirement qui rentre dans
le système de capitalisation
alors quelles réponses pouvez vous
apporter pourquoi les mettre sous le
régime universel qui n'a d'ailleurs plus
n'ont laissé leur la spécificité de leur
caisse c'est ce que je vous demande et
c'est ce qu'il vous demande je vous
remercie de 1376 c'est madame dalloz qui
le défend non qui le défend il est
défendu très bien alors monsieur le
rapporteur et chers collègues je pense
que nous avons eu déjà ce débat
plusieurs reprises aussi ce sera un avis
défavorable
la présente je suis le député d'or vous
avez 7
cette capacité j'ai bien compris au
travers d'un amendement qui est assez
récurrent quand même un sur voilà et
vous comprenez le fait que le rapporteur
vous dise bon déjà discuté du sujet on a
bien compris que vous pensiez que
c'était pas universelle
d'où vous répond que ce système sera dit
vercel parce que l'ensemble des français
verront aussi épique et les mêmes règles
ils feront les mêmes efforts pour avoir
les mêmes droits
bon et vous vous défendez sur le fond a
d'ailleurs un projet politique
auxquelles j'ai déjà accusé réception
plusieurs reprises mais je joue bien le
faire j'ai bien compris que vous étiez
plutôt sur un projet qui est d'ailleurs
assez proche de ce qui a pu diffuser un
moment donné par les les professions
libérales ses terres d'un pass 1 et puis
ensuite d'avoir des spécificités
professionnelles ou statutaire moi je
sais pas la même lecture gouvernement a
pas la même lecture
pourquoi gouvernement a pas la même
lecture parce que d'abord la réalité de
des parcours des médecins que vous
évoquez aujourd'hui c'est déjà des
parcours où ils sont affiliés à
plusieurs caisses différentes la réalité
des parcours de médecins c'est que
certains peuvent décider d'exercer de
façon libérale pendant un temps et puis
ensuite de passer salariés ou l' inverse
et que ses perspectives de l'évolution
même si vous avez raison c'est sans
doute pas la même chose quand on est
spécialiste dans une partie vraiment
extrêmement pointue de ce métier à mais
quand même pour la majorité des médecins
ça peut aussi avoir du sens que de se
dire que les parcours professionnels
seront pas tout à fait les mêmes ensuite
sur le fond de ces de ses débats par
rapport aux libéraux nous avons été très
attentifs et nous le sommes nous le
sommes à ce qu' il y ait une pérennité
de leur activité économique et c'est
pour ça en avons d'ailleurs des battues
déjà à plusieurs reprises depuis une
semaine mais je vous ai invités à
revenir à l'article 21
nous avons choisi de compenser
l'augmentation de cotisations vieillesse
en ramenant l'assiette de cg des
indépendants et des libéraux sur les
mêmes bases que celles des salariés et
donc de les remettre
si j'ose m'exprimer ainsi à égalité avec
les salariés donc à chaque fois la
lecture qu'on doit avoir pour les
professions libérales
c'est une lecture certes de progression
un certain nombre de cas c'est pas le
cas pour les baies de saint gilles bas
mais dans un certain nombre de cas
progression des cotisations vieillesse
est dans un autre cas aussi à mettre en
phase de baisse des charges notamment
par la cgt puis le troisième point de
vous souligner sur le fond la
indirectement avec les médecins et ça a
été vrai je les dis pour les avocats
c'est l'augmentation qu'il y aura des
pensions derrière parce que s'agit pas
dire qu'on demande aux uns et aux autres
de cotiser plus mais il faut regarder
aussi quelle sera l'évolution de leur
pension alors qu'il sera significative
notamment gelé déjà dit pour les avocats
pour les avocats aux plus petits revenus
puisque nous allons acter que il y aura
des progressions de pension de plus de
10 points pour ces professions libérales
sur les médecins sur les médecins c'est
un peu l'inversé puisqu'ils ont eu un
taux de cotisations plus élevées que le
28 12 que nous proposons moi j'ai
rencontré à plusieurs reprises les
représentants des médecins et je le dis
pour ma part mon équipe aussi bien sûr
et puis le haut commissaire jean paul
delevoye bien avant moi lorsque la
question qui nous posent au même titre
d'ailleurs que pour les avocats c'est
est ce que nous pourrons voir perdurer
de notre caisse dans le cadre d'une
délégation de gestion de services de la
ceni rue la réponse c'est oui quels sont
vos projets en la matière donc je les
dis à eux comme à d'autres mais quel est
le projet derrière ça est ce que c'est
juste d'avoir une caisse ou est ce que
c'est d'avoir une perspective
particulière donc de maintien peut-être
d'un haut niveau de cotisation de
manière à avoir un étage supplémentaire
tout cela se construit avec eux je le
dis comme pour l'ensemble des
professions libérales
le gouvernement est à l'écouté des
projets qui pourraient vouloir nous
porte et je crois l'avoir démontré très
franchement il vous les connaissez bien
donc vous savez qu'ils ont pas pu vous
dire le contraire
lorsqu'ils m'ont rencontré j'ai été très
explicite là dessus alors il m'a écouté
venez avec votre projet regardons la
viabilité économique de ce projet bien
sûr que les dispositions de délégation
de gestion de services pourront exister
pour vous comme elles pourront exister
pour les autres construisons ce cas
l'ensemble et on tue ce n'est pas dans
l'urgence un jeu rappelle qu'il s'agit
pas de imaginé un dispositif qui va
démarrer lundi matin puisque nous avons
toute la période de transition pour
construire cela donc vous avez nous
avons 17 ans on réussit pas prendre 17
ans là on a tous les cas franchement en
dehors de l'expression le temps
nécessaire et suffisant pour faire bien
les choses avec les médecins comme avec
d'autres monsieur le député merci
monsieur le ministre donc votre avis est
défavorable monsieur le ministre bien
donc je vous informe que sur la série
qui va venir les amendements identiques
26 1731 et suivants jusqu'à 28 58
je suis saisi par le groupe gdr d'une
demande de scrutin public le scrutin est
annoncée dans l'enceinte de l'assemblée
nationale madame dalloz vous avez
demandé la parole et madame la
présidente
on le voit depuis le début de l'examen
de ce texte alors que vous affirmer son
caractère universel qui l'y a énormément
de questionnements or la semaine dans le
courant de la semaine dernière nous
avons vu
différentes professions les avocats nous
avons vu les pompiers vous renvoyez
d'ailleurs un projet de loi porté par
une proposition de projet de loi porté
par votre majorité enfin on a vu aussi
la problématique des agriculteurs ce
matin on a parlé des droits familiaux
concernant notamment la protection des
femmes
on vient d'aborder les médecins il y a
les marins il y à chaque fois qu'on
aborde les danseuses également chaque
fois qu'on aborde une profession il y a
il existe un flou où est votre côté
universel le conseil d'état d'ailleurs
sur le registre dit il estime le conseil
d'état estime que les différences de
traitement maintenu entre assurés
relevant du système universel de
retraite est rattaché le cas échéant à
des régimes distinctes établi par la
prose le projet de loi doivent donc être
justifiée par les mêmes motifs que ce
que retient le conseil constitutionnel
pour l'appréciation au sein d'un régime
d'un même régime de principe d'égalité
devant la loi et devant devant la loi en
rapport direct et devant les charges
publiques
c'est quand même une considération est
un élément important dans le débat
puisque l'universalité n'est pas prouvée
l'égalité non plus et la justice de ces
principes ne sont pas retenu le conseil
d'état vous en appel à vous reprendre en
main si je peux prendre l'expression
actuelle mais la réalité c'est que vous
êtes en train et sur tous les sujets que
nous avons abordé d'emmener les français
dans une une comment dire une
malhonnêteté intellectuelle sur les
femmes on l'a vu on l'a dénoncé ce matin
sur les avocats aussi des médecins jean
pierre dure d'or vient d'en parler des
agriculteurs vous ne dites à aucun
moment que pour financer le régime
retraite à l'équivalent d'un smic mais
qu'ils aient cotisé à l'équivalent d'un
smic c'est un mensonge sinon
s'il madame la députée alors pour le
groupe la république en marge et deux
demandes de parole monsieur breivik ou
même rila qu'est-ce-qui malabry lac à
ifs
vous êtes très aimable anna vers l'inde
envers l'autre mais il faut choisir
monsieur boris vite
oui merci madame la présidente non mais
simplement pour revenir sur les médecins
évidemment parce que on on a un système
actuellement
alors je m'opposerai à mon confrère mais
on a un système qui finalement
aujourd'hui ne fonctionne pas forcément
merveilleusement bien et puis moi je je
je je dors vous parliez de des médecins
qui s'interrompt qui s'interrogent au
delà trois passes enfin moi je ne sais
pas je suis peut-être juste un petit
généraliste mais trois passes et c'est
quand même un niveau de revenu qui est
quand même assez important en sachant
qu'il ya déjà une retraite par
capitalisation qui est énorme dans notre
dans notre système
et puis bon je pense que le ministre l'a
bien souligné
aujourd'hui il ya des discussions qui
sont en cours il ya une volonté vraiment
importante d'écouter tout le monde
d'ailleurs on parlait pas on parle pas
que des médecins mais de d'écouter
toutes les professions de manière
pérenne de manière précise sur ce qu'ils
ont envie de faire pour la suite
et là dessus sur les médecins je pense
qu'on a besoin de voir l'évolution des
professions
on a des professions qui évolue avec du
libéral avec du salariat je pense c'est
une nouvelle façon d'exercer nos
confrères les plus jeunes en ont besoin
et puis il ya une chose qui est très
importante quand même a souligné dans
notre réforme c'est que l'on n'a pas
beaucoup parlé s'agissant précisément
des médecins c'est que nous ça nous
permettra de partir plus tôt à la
retraite dont je crois que quand même ça
sur ce système là c'est important de
souligner c'est une très bonne réforme
on permet de garder le même niveau de
pension avec moins de capitalisation
contre toute attente et en partant plus
tôt à la retraite finalement je trouve
que les discussions sont plutôt positifs
s'agissant des médecins voilà merci
monsieur vareuse l'icm monsieur petit
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est vrai c'est intéressant c'est
plus un jour sans fin puisque on a
quelque chose un petit exemple nouveau
moi je reviens sur les 30% que ses
médecins ont perdu sur les 2400 que
votre amie qui gagne 250 mille euros par
an a perdu nous nous disons que à partir
du moment où on a une retraite qui doit
être de l'ordre de 7000 8000 euros par
mois on a une pension de 7000 8000 euros
par mois eh bien oui c'est très bien de
ramener de la cotisation dans le système
général ça va être de l'ordre de 100
milliards d'euros par an qui va revenir
dans le système général et de considérer
que le système général qui est chargé de
réduire les inégalités parce que c'est
un régime solidaire considère qu'au-delà
de 8000 euros par mois on n'est pas
obligé de multiplier proportionnellement
est d'arriver à des pensions du régime
général à 15 milles vingt mille euros
par mois dont jusqu'à 8000 euros par
mois au quai à partir de là il faut
ramener les pertes que vous dites
les pertes que vous décrivez à une base
qui est une base solide r ça réduit
c'est exactement la définition de la
réduction des inégalités par le système
de retraites c'est la définition de la
réduction des inégalités qui est
monsieur petit monsieur jumelles on a
fait référence plusieurs fois depuis
huit jours à ambroise croizat où on a
compris que sur le fond l'héritage de
croiser a été déchiré déchiqueté est
cassé mais même sur la forme n'est pas
croiser à qui veut figurez vous que le
discours dans brasse croisa le 8 août
1946 dès la première page
alors il lui il avait envie de
rassembler tout le monde
ils voulaient l'unanimité sur son texte
il voulait réconcilier la france et non
pas la diviser la fragmenter mais dès la
première page en bronze croisa ministres
communistes du travail s'adresse aux
médecins dans ces termes je m'adresse
donc au delà de cette assemblée aux
représentants du corps médical dont je
ne sous estime pas la haute conscience
qui a toujours tenu une place très
importante dans nos pays nous respectons
d'une façon toute spéciale cette
fonction honorable qui ne cesse de
rendre des grands services à la
population de notre de notre pays
m'adressant donc au corps médical je lui
demande d'éliminer
autre crainte en vue d'une collaboration
loyale et sans réserve à la sécurité
sociale
je vous renvoie au texte fondateur de la
sécurité sociale mais ça pour dire que
sur le fond vous n'êtes évidemment pas
au rendez vous du conseil national de la
résistance mais sur la forme il vous
faut encore faire un peu d'efforts pour
y compris embrasser ce qui je pense aux
médecins aux vocations aussi être des
acteurs à part entière du projet tel
n'est pas le cas
les interventions de nos collègues l'ont
démontré merci monsieur jumelles
monsieur la chaux et les trois passes et
les huit passes prenons un autre exemple
votre ami qui gagne 3 126 leurs parents
monsieur le petit si on garde le plafond
actuel à 8 passes il payerait 28,12 % de
cotisations sur le total de cette somme
et l'entreprise paye réelles 16,68 % sur
le même total en baissant le plafond à
trois passes ces taux de cotisation sont
valables jusqu'à 120 mille euros mais
baisse ensuite à 2,80 pour le salarié et
1,69 pour les entreprises sur la part de
salaire entre 120 milles et c'est 329
euros ce qui représente quand même
209 mille euros donc au total sur cette
part de salaires au dessus de 120 mille
euros c'est cinquante trois mille euros
qui échappe aux régimes de retraite du
fait des cotisations du salarié et 31330
euros au titre des baisses de
cotisations patronales
donc pour un seul employé payé 329 1000
euros par an votre réforme c'est une
baisse de 84 1300 euros en brut qui
échapperont chaque année au système de
retraite par répartition et qui auront
nourrir le régime par capitalisation
cela est un fait monsieur merci monsieur
la chaux bien alors nous allons
mettre aux voix chez amendements
identiques
ayant reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour et qui est contre
ils ne sont pas adoptées nous en venons
aux amendements identiques 26 1731 et
suivants monsieur brunel monsieur
jumelles qui le défend monsieur jumelles
oui on va commencer à parler des profs
c'est bien ça terme inéquitable
considérer qu'il ya défendu s'est
défendu monsieur le rapporteur
défavorable mais chez le ministre
merci madame la présidente sont
effectivement c'est un amendement à
l'article le premier déposé par le
groupe gdr qui vise à substituer au mot
universel le mot inéquitable donc
effectivement c'est ce genre de débat
qui a peu d'intérêt qui a été renouvelé
à x reprises et qui nous conduit est
toujours à l'article 20 linea 11 ce
matin hamdi défavorable merci monsieur
le ministre mabri lac
merci madame la présence simplement pour
rappeler à monsieur jumelles que hier
nous avons eu un débat très intéressant
sur le terme universel et que nous avons
d'ailleurs et que nous avons d'ailleurs
hier introduit le mot dignité suite
justement à un amendement de votre
groupe qui faisait référence à la
constitution qui faisait référence à la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme dont je reconnais c'est ici que
par cet amendement vous-même
reconnaissez quand même l'universalité
de ce texte
l'universalité de ce que nous proposons
est donc reconnaissant que notre réforme
elle est universelle n'est certes elle
n'est pas uniforme car nous tenons
compte de la diversité des carrières de
nos concitoyens mais cette réforme est
universel mais elle n'est en rien
inéquitable si madame la députée je vais
donc le mettre aux voix par scrutin
public chacun regagne sa place
le scrutin est ouvert le scrutin est
clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votants 92
exprimé 79 majorité 40 pour 11 contre 68
l'assemblée n'a pas adopté alors
l'amendement 497 qui fait l'objet d'un
sous-amendement donc c'est madame me
alors sur le 497 c'est monsieur sermier
merci madame la présidente oui monsieur
le ministre vous nous parlez d'un
système universel l'universalité peut
exister mais il faut savoir ce qu'on
veut en faire et pour nous
l'universalité
c'est aussi la solidarité et
l'universalité doit servir aux plus
modestes certains de nos concitoyens
d'ailleurs qui ont travaillé dans des
métiers difficiles que ce soit donc aux
intempéries que ce soit sur des porcs de
lourdes charges soit dans des métiers de
stress donc il convient d'inscrire dans
cette fois qu'un système universel de
pénibilité sera créé à partir de ce
texte de façon à ce que ceux qui sont
les plus abîmées de la vie puisse partir
un peu plus tôt c'est un amendement de
notre collègue pierre cordier
merci monsieur sermier le
sous-amendement 42500 présente monsieur
sy merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre il s'agit d'un sous
amendement de précision rédactionnelle
par cet amendement nous voulons créer un
système universel de pénibilité afin que
les assurés en situation d'incapacité
permanente due à leur situation
professionnelle puis je vais d'épicier
d'un âge de départ avancé nous en avons
déjà parlé mais je veux rappeler par
exemple que dans mon département de la
loire de nombreux ouvriers de la
sidérurgie en particulier ont une
carrière difficile à cause de la chaleur
des fours des fourneaux pendant des
charges lourdes à porter même si la
modernisation de l'industrie a permis
des progrès des agriculteurs devraient
également pourra bénéficier de ce
système
merci monsieur
le député monsieur le rapporteur merci
chers collègues eux
concernant la prise en compte de la
pénibilité
je pense qu'on ne doit pas se contenter
des discours qu'il faut préférer les
actes et c'est ce que nous faisons et ce
que nous faisons notamment à travers ce
système universel de retraite notamment
en élargissant notamment en élargissant
le comte pénibilité dans le futur
système qui va nous faire passer avant
la réforme de 200 de 227 mille personnes
bénéficieront par an à 4 146 mille
personnes par ailleurs nous aurons des
amendements qui seront discutés aux
articles 33 déposé par le gouvernement
qui nous permettront d'aller encore plus
loin et sur lesquels notamment notre
collègue jacques maire a eu l'occasion
de s'exprimer à plusieurs reprises
depuis le début de nos débats tout comme
le ministre si ce sera une demande de
retrait ou un avis défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre nous la
présidente pour cet amendement du député
pierre cordier défendu par le député
servier rapporteur monsieur le député
vous a dit que ce sujet de l'habilité un
sujet d'abord sera évoqué très
complètement dans le titre 2 puisqu'il y
aura des départs anticipés au titre de
la pénibilité
et puis aussi tout simplement parce que
on l'a évoqué déjà en fait dans cet
article 20 à l'alinéa 6 assez largement
d'ailleurs qu' un certain nombre de
groupes d'opposition et si vous les
supprimez et qui heureusement a été
maintenue par une large majorité puisque
nous avons très clairement indiqué dans
l'alinéa 6 que dans les dispositifs de
solidarité il y aurait des départs
anticipés au titre de la pénibilité
voilà c'est pour ça que vous faites
cette demande de retrait des fois des
faveurs à boucher députée monsieur minus
vous leur tirez vous lui m'a donné mes
chers collègues ils sont maintenus donc
je vais mettre aux voix le
sous-amendement de monsieur signé rien
reçu un avis défavorable
ah pardon il ya les demandes de prise de
parole monsieur le président votre
pardonnez moi vous avez la parole c'est
un sujet important madame la présidente
on l'a déjà évoqué mais ciblés comme
comme on n'est pas du tout chez eux
qu'on arrive au bout du texte faut bien
évoquer les sujets avant qu'il ne
disparaisse de la discussion
parlementaire et je crois que nous
n'avons pas tout à fait la même
conception est votre conception n'est
pas claire sur la pénibilité nous avons
introduit la notion de pénibilité dans
un texte sur les retraites la droite qui
a introduit cette notion de pénibilité
contre contre la vie d'ailleurs à
l'époque du patronat le le sujet de la
pénibilité n'est pas un sujet par métier
et lorsque vous évoquez la pénibilité
lorsque dans la conférence de
financement en parle de pénibilité on
évoque des discussions par branche et
par métier ça veut dire que c'est pas un
système universel c'est un système par
métier c'était assez différentes
l'idée générale c'est de dire et vous
évoquez aussi les comptes de prévention
les comptes de les comptes de pénibilité
le lait le compte de pénibilité lui il
doit intégrer des points supplémentaires
pour justement permettre une
reconversion des salariés mais pas pour
agir sur l'âge où les capacités à partir
en retraite
donc il est très important que la
pénibilité au sens universel du terme
elle concerne absolument tout le monde
et de la même manière et on doit
constater l'usure physique de quelqu'un
au moins physique pour le moment
psychologique peut être un jour quand on
sera le faire l'usure physique confronté
à un certain nombre d'éléments
d'exposition durant la carrière
professionnelle à ce moment là ça
devient la vérité pour absolument tout
le monde sinon on en crée autant de deux
cas spéciaux ou de régimes spéciaux que
deux régimes de pénibilité la pénibilité
doit être réellement universel merci
monsieur le monsieur woerth alors sur
les amendements 24700 ruby je vais vous
donner la parole 24 1779 et les
amendements 24 1157 est identique
je suis saisi
le groupe l'est républicain d'une
demande de scrutin public le scrutin est
annoncée dans l'enceinte de l'assemblée
nationale monsieur jumelles bon on a
débattu de ce sujet moi je suis
convaincu que avec cette réforme puisque
l'âge déquilibre repousse l'âge de
départ les métiers pénibles vont être
dégradée et les gens qui n'ont pas les
mêmes points de vie en bonne santé ne
seront pas épargnés mais à ce moment du
débat il faut quand même qu'on soit
lucide on va pas aller jusqu'au bout on
ne sait vous le savez mieux que d'où
d'ailleurs puisque vous l'avez décidé et
vous connaissez le jour l'heure avant
même que le texte n'ait été déposée sur
le bureau de l'assemblée et non moi j'ai
un certain nombre de questions
les marins article c'est être envoyées
aux ordonnances
comment allez vous prendre en compte la
pénibilité des marins tiens un marrant
transmanche qui fait démarrer de quinze
jours qui travaille douche 12 heures de
suite dans des conditions donc de
pénibilité avérée
est ce que le statut des marins l'âge de
départ anticipé à la retraite la pension
de réversion versée aux veuves du marin
décédé
les taux de cotisation en fonction de la
catégorie est ce que tout cela va être
garantis parce que j'ai appelé moi
le président de l'association nationale
des pensionnés de la marine marchande ni
me dit silence radio on n'a aucune info
j'ai appelé la fédé cgt des marins
retraités ils me disent on a aucune info
donc j'ai appelé une association qui
n'est pas réputé pour être crypto
révolutionnaire et j'ai appelé un
syndicat qui a une légitimité à pouvoir
discuter de ces sujets là donc quand on
dit que les ordonnances sont des chèques
en blanc et des des leurs pour éviter de
régler les problèmes d'avoir trop de
problèmes en même temps on en est
l'illustration non est-ce que vous
pouvez nous répondre sur les questions
de pénibilité monsieur à ce moment du
débat puisque la semaine prochaine
l'arme nucléaire va être actionné le
président de la république va à pouvait
appuyer sur le bouton et on va pas
examiner le texte
donc est-ce que vous pouvez répondre à
nos questions merci monsieur jumelles
monsieur la tombe
si madame la présidente je voudrais dire
à nos collègues qui nous reparle de
pénibilité que c'est un sujet que nous
avons abordé samedi et dimanche
juste pour faire le rappel pour vous
dire que on est bien dans l'article 1
avec un principe est que nous avons
inscrit ce principe dans l'alinéa 6
quand nous disons de façon très claire à
ce titre le système universel de
retraites tient compte des situations
pouvant conduire certains assurés pour
des raisons tenant compte alors être de
leur état de santé ou leur carrière a
anticipé leur départ en retraite
on est bien là dans un principe qui
tient compte de la pénibilité qui tient
compte de la pénibilité pour à la fois
leur permettent d'avoir des carrières
différentes qui permettent d'éviter
d'aggraver la pénibilité ou d'anticiper
le départ en retraite
on est bien dans un article dans
l'article 20 sur des principes vous nous
demander d'inscrire le principe il est
déjà inscrits à l'alinéa 6 merci
monsieur le député mais chez le
rapporteur monsieur mer oui je répondrai
pas sur les marins monsieur jumelles je
répondrais surtout sur l'interpellation
de monsieur woerth qui effectivement
reprend un peu à son compte une espèce
de formulation rapide je crois du medef
sur lequel quand on traite de pénibilité
concernant les quatre acteurs a exclu
recréerait des régimes spéciaux
je pense est important de refaire le
point sur ce sujet de façon à peu près 6
mars que nous sommes en plein débat sur
le sujet on dans cet hémicycle entre
partenaires sociaux et depuis plusieurs
mois vous le savez monsieur woerth
il y a déjà des accords concernant les
facteurs a exclu qu'ils définissent des
critères de pénibilité dans certaines
branches pas assez faut aller plus loin
ce que nous souhaitons nous de notre
part c'est qu'effectivement quand il y a
eu de la part du medef avec raison le
fait d'indiquer l'impossibilité
notamment pour les pme de définir quels
étaient les métiers pour lesquels
l'enregistrement de la méditation de
chaque charge load était impossible il
fallait passer à autre chose
cet autre chose c'est pas
c'est possible ça se définit pas par
l'état sauf si j'aime cette mais ça ne
marche pas mais ça défini par l'accord
de branche et ensuite qu'à la question à
en tirer que nous appartiennent de
regarder de ce point de vue nous
adressons nous mêmes ici et cela n'est
nullement un message aux partenaires
sociaux n'a que en première lecture
je le répète nous faisons le pari que la
conférence sociale qui n'a pas terminé
ses travaux sur notamment la pénibilité
puissent arriver à tirer les
conséquences de ces métiers pénibles
notamment pour les risques légaux
ergonomique et sur le plan de la
réparation
c'est à eux de nous proposer des choses
évidemment je le dis solennellement
encore une fois ci au moment de la
deuxième lecture les partenaires sociaux
ne sont pas arrivés à élaborer un
dispositif de réparation pour les
facteurs exclu nous l'avons dit nous
prendrons nos responsabilités
merci merci monsieur mer alors donc oui
madame panneaux rappel au règlement sur
la base de quels fondements s'il vous
plaît merci à madame la présidente alors
sur le fondement de l'article 81 sur les
députés veille à prévenir ou à faire
cesser immédiatement toute situation de
conflit d'intérêts madame la présidente
pour une fois que je siège dans cet
hémicycle je souhaiterais vous rendre un
petit service chez cette semaine jeter
un coup d'oeil sur le cours de la bourse
et je souhaite alerter l'un d'entre vous
car d'après euronext le cours d'axa a
baissé d'un point 45 % d'ailleurs il n'a
fait que chuter la semaine passée avec 3
47 % jeudi dernier sur cinq jours le
cours a connu une variation d'environ -5
22%
monsieur jacques maire j'ai lu votre
déclaration d'intérêt que vous possédiez
13 1836 par chez axa pour un total de
358 1935 euros j'ai donc cru bon de vous
prévenir
d'ailleurs j'ai lu que non seulement
vous y avait des parts mais que vous
avez même passé dix ans dans sa
direction aux ressources humaines puis
au développement international du groupe
à la tête de la stratégie d'axa en
europe président de la filiale d'axa en
hongrie mais attendez axe assez bien le
célèbre assure le même
se réjouit de la réforme des retraites
de vos gardes de votre gouvernement et
avec blackrock à son capital donc si je
comprends bien si à la suite d'une
politique publique favorable axa vendée
plus d'assurance l'entreprise serait
alors encore plus coté en bourse et vous
enrichirez d'avantagé ce que j'ai bon
monsieur jacques maire et je vais vous
lire donc l'article 2 relatif à la
transparence de la vie publique celle-ci
définit la notion de conflit d'intérêts
par toute situation d'interférence entre
un intérêt public et des intérêts
publics ou privés qui est de nature à
influencer ou paraître influencer
l'exercice indépendant impartial et
objectif d'une fonction pour résumer
vous allez tirer un bénéfice priver de
cette réforme dont vous êtes un des
artisans et d'ailleurs vous avez vous
avez dû vous le dire aussi puisque vous
annoncer à libération que vous avez
vendu vos parts ils vous ont relancé
plusieurs fois pour savoir quand vous
les aviez vendus pas de réponse
avez vous demandé à la déontologue s'il
s'agissait d'un conflit d'intérêts merci
s'il vous plaît chers collègues votre
notre collègue a fait un rappel au
règlement sur un fondement qui existe
dans le règlement auquel monsieur le
maire au titre d'une mise en cause
personnelle peut répondre ou pas donc
c'est pas la peine de s'agiter monsieur
le maire souhaitait vous répondre
monsieur le maire va répond ensuite je
donnerai la parole pour un autre rappel
au règlement effectivement j'ai pas
passer ma vie à courir les mandats
électoraux
j'ai pas passer ma vie à cumuler les
fonctions j'ai pas passer ma vie
effectivement dans le confort d'une
carrière particulière et je suis
extrêmement fier d'avoir donné dix ans
de ma vie
un des groupes français qui sont parmi
les fleurons de la france à
l'international
et je le dis avec une assurance je
dirais une sérénité totale
je suis absolument veut dire convaincu
que les français ne veulent pas des
députés qu'ils soient des députés des
professionnels de la politique pendant
40 ans et je dis simplement la chose
suivante tout ce qui est le concerne et
dans évidemment ma déclaration à l'
achat tvp je n'ai absolument aucune
je dirais informations supplémentaires à
livrer et ma bonne foi mon éthique mon
exigence je crois que sur l'ensemble de
ces bons on la connaît merci m fabre
madame fabre madame fabre vous avez il
souhaitait faire un rappel au règlement
non planes de lavernhe j'ai souhaité
intervenir
merci madame la présidente
j'interviens effectivement au banc en
tant que vice présidente de la
commission spéciale et pour la qualité
de nos débats
la bonne tenue de nos débats hélas ce à
quoi nous venons d'assister aujourd'hui
à la fois en tant que parlementaire en
tant que vice présidente
je trouve ça extrêmement grave une mise
en cause personnelle et sur le ton et
sur le fond de cette nature là ne donne
pas une bonne image de notre démocratie
ne donne pas une image de notre
parlement et nous sommes capables et
nous l'avons démontré dans le débat
d'idées de bien mieux je ne souhaite pas
que tous quel que soit le texte
quel que soit le député nous nous
transformions dans un hémicycle où
aurait lieu une sorte de chasse aux
sorcières absolument pas justifiée nous
devons travailler sur le fond des sujets
chacun de nous a un parcours chacun de
nous poursuit un objectif d'intérêt
général et je souhaite que nous fassions
cela dans le respect les uns des autres
de laval monsieur bazin vous souhaitez
faire un rappel au règlement sur le
fondement de sur le même fondement que
utilisé par madame panneaux voilà je
crois qu'on a tous ici des parcours
professionnels
qui doivent être respectés et qui
viennent enrichir notre mandat de
parlementaire pour autant moi je je peux
dire que lorsqu'on a des sujets sur
lesquels on va être amené à se prononcer
qui peuvent être en lien avec une
activité par passé et je crois que
personne n'a de leçon à donner mais
juste à apprendre aussi de des réflexes
qu'on doit tous avoir la déontologue
m'avait fait part pour pour ce qui me
concerne où j'ai travaillé dans le
logement et où j'ai été missionné comme
orateur de mon groupe par le président
jacob sur la loi est lent la
dermatologue nous invite à une chose
quand on commence les débats dans la
première prise de parole de pouvoir
préciser à tous les membres qu'on a eu
une activité dans le domaine
une fois qu'on l'a dit au tout début
c'est dit tout le monde ça qu'il ya eu
une expérience dans le domaine et je
pense que ça participe à la clarté et la
lisibilité et ça évite qu'on soit coupée
après dans le débat sur ces sujets qui
pourraient interférer
donc je crois que on doit prendre ses
réflexes tous
maintenant il faut qu'on avance sur le
sur le texte parce que on a fort à faire
et on le voit il ya encore des questions
qui restent en suspens et qui doit être
traité
merci monsieur plaisait bien alors je
propose que nous tenons mais le débat
est clos sur ce sujet tout doublé toutes
les opinions se sont exprimés donc nous
allons procéder au vote à main levée sur
l'amendement le sous-amendement 42000
tant d'échecs je sais plus où j'en suis
moi il est mais trouvera et celui bien
donc je reprends sur le sous-amendement
42 1542 monsieur minery qui a reçu un
avis défavorable qui est pour et qui est
contre il n'est pas adoptée je mets au
voile amendement 497 de monsieur cordier
défendu par monsieur sermier ayant reçu
un avis défavorable qui est pour et qui
est contre il n'est pas adoptée
amendements soumis à discussion commune
alors j'ai appelé scrutin public donc
c'est madame küster qui défend le 24
oui merci madame la présidente je
profite de cet amendement qui vise à
maintenir le régime autonome des
retraites des avocats pour aussi
présenté celui que je voulais faire dans
le cadre de l'article 2 mais avant que
nous arrivions à l'article 2 je préfère
assurer maintenant ainsi la caisse
nationale des barreaux français a
démontré la bonne gestion des
cotisations des avocats puisqu'elle
dispose à date de près de 2,5 milliards
d'euros de réserves et d'ici 2025
elle devrait atteindre les 3,5 milliards
d'euros la réforme telle qu'elle est
prévue va augmenter le niveau des
cotisations des avocats tout en
réduisant le niveau de leur pension
le régime universel prévoit en effet
d'après votre texte et selon les cas des
augmentations de cotisations pouvant
aller jusqu'à 60% de plus rappelons le
les avocats sont des axes des
auxiliaires de service public de la
justice
à ce titre la spécificité de leur
profession justifie d'une caisse
autonome
en effet ce sont notamment les garanties
qu'elle offre un minimum de 17 mille
euros de pension de base assurée pour
tous les avocats
quel que soit le volume de leurs
cotisations ce qui permet d'assurer la
représentation des clients les plus
démunis en supprimant cette garantie le
projet de loi prend le risque d'une
répercussion de la hausse des
cotisations sur les justiciables les
droits de la défense en serait donc
inévitablement atteint de même que la
garantie des droits et l'accès au juge
cet amendement donc prévoit que la
nation
à renty le maintien du régime de
retraite des personnes affiliées de
plein droit à la caisse nationale des
barreaux français
il en va de l'intérêt des avocats mais
également des français dans leur
ensemble
je vous remercie merci madame küster
alors une série d'amendements identiques
le 24 1157 monsieur vigier merci madame
la présidente monsieur le ministre
franchement sur la caisse de retraite
autonome des avocats est ce que vous le
souhaitez faire je ne vous comprends pas
les avocats ne vous ont rien demandé
leur caisse est autonome et même elle
est excédentaire ils sont solidaires
puisqu'il reverse dans le pot commun
hauteur d'à peu près 100 millions
d'euros par an et avec votre réforme
ça va être pour les avocats la triple
peine la cotisation va doubler de 14% à
28 % leur retraite qui en moyenne et
2600 euros par mois va passer à 1000
euros par mois et surtout leurs fonds de
réserve qui est de 2 5 milliards d'euros
va disparaître puisque vous allez le
prendre
j'ai peur qu'avec cette réforme sur les
caisses autonomes des avocats vous allez
faire disparaître je dis bien
disparaître les petits cabinets alors
monsieur le ministre revenait sur cette
réforme notamment pour les caisses de
retraite autonome des avocats je le
redis il ne vous ont rien demandé
il ne coûte rien ils sont solidaires
avec la nation et simplement cet
amendement vise à maintenir le régime
autonome de retraite des avocats
merci monsieur vigier le 24 1158 me
suivent et un merci madame la présidente
oui un sujet déjà largement évoqué mon
interrogation porte sur ce que vous
allez nous répondre ensuite sur la
question de l'abattement de csg
expliquez-nous enfin comment vous allez
procéder pour pouvoir faire un
abattement spécial de csg sur une
profession particulière alors que la csg
si j'ai bien compris la fiscalité
s'applique à tous puisqu'elle est
également universel de l'amendement
mais vous pourrez reprendre la parole
après si vous le souhaitez mais pas sur
cet amendement
donc il est défendu le 24 1438 oui
madame pinel oui merci madame la
présidente cet amendement présenté par
notre collègue paul andré colombani et
que je défends bien volontiers propose
que le régime autonome de retraite des
avocats puissent être maintenus
je rappelle que la caisse des avocats
n'est pas financée par l'état n'est pas
alimentée par la solidarité nationale
mais que les avocats reverse 100
millions au régime général
cette caisse j'insiste garantit
également l'indépendance des avocats
ce sont nous le savons d acteur
indispensable de notre système
judiciaire les avocats permettent
l'accès aux droits des justiciables
la hausse des taux de cotisation induite
par votre réforme rendra plus coûteux le
recours à leurs services donc certaines
personnes n'y auront plus accès par
ailleurs je m'inquiète du maillage
territorial de la profession puisque
votre projet donc sa bombe a fragilisé
les jeunes avocats et certains cabinets
notamment ceux qui auront des problèmes
de trésorerie ceux qui ont beaucoup de
clients bénéficiaires de l'aide
juridictionnelle ou les commissions
d'office ce qui favorisera les cabinets
important et qui sont bien souvent
situés dans les villes ou dans les
métropoles au détriment d'une partie du
territoire au détriment d'une partie de
nos concitoyens qui auront plus
difficilement accès à la justice ait
accès au droit
c'est la raison pour laquelle cet
amendement propose donc son maintien
dans le régime
le maintien du régime autonome des
avocats de madame pinel le 24 1641 n'est
pas défendu le 24 1962 monsieur cinieri
maximum la présente monsieur le ministre
actuellement des avocats cotisent à un
régime de retraite totalement autonome
la caisse nationale du bureau français
créé en 1948 bien 1948 qui ne coûte rien
d'état et qui est solidaire puisque il
reverse 100 millions d'euros régime
général une nationalisation de leurs
retraites serait d'abord injuste
à ce que ce régime autofinancé
al'inverse de ceux de la sncf vient de
la rta pardon ratp où edf payés par les
contribuables n'a pas eu recours à
l'état et n'a pas être à être affiliés
au régime universel proposé puisqu'il
excédentaire par ailleurs cette
nationalisation serait aussi un jusqu'à
la complémentaire à laquelle les avocats
cotisent en fonction de leurs revenus
permet une redistribution solidaire
défend de cette corporation
beaucoup de professionnels du droit
estime qu'une telle réforme on aura un
effet très négatif sur le statut des
jeunes collaborateurs avocats dans
plusieurs barreaux et que qui via un
réel risque pour d'accès au droit des
français car de nombreux cabinets vont
fermer et qui va créer des déserts
juridique et judiciaire sur projet de
loi prévoit que les cotisations retraite
des avocats passerait de 14 % à 28 %
sans bénéfices sur les pensions il se
pourrait même que les avocats les plus
modestes ou à leur pension baisser de
près de 30%
cet amendement propose par conséquent de
maintenir le régime autonome de retraite
des avocats
merci monsieur cinieri le 24 1965 n'est
pas défendu le 29 1634 non plus le 30
4263 non plus le 35 1887 non plus bien
alors sur cette discussion commune
monsieur le rapporteur
si madame la présidente je pense que ce
débat nous l'avons vu à plusieurs
reprises en commission mais même ici au
cours de la dernière semaine
aussi la vie ne changera pas ce sera un
avis défavorable par contre juste
quelques éléments de réponse d'abord sur
le fait que l'on maintient l'activité
quand même du cnbf qui continuent à
fonctionner par convention avec
la future cnrj le futur cn et rue dont
on discutera à l'article 54 de ceux de
ce projet de loi par ailleurs deux
choses on ne touche pas au fonds de
réserve et troisième point sur
l'indépendance des avocats avec la
création du système universel de
retraite à aucun moment leur
indépendance des remises en question
tout comme l'indépendance des magistrats
tout comme l'indépendance des membres du
conseil constitué tout comme notre
propre indépendance
à nous les parlementaires n'est pas
remise en question par la mise en place
de ce système universel de retraite vous
remercie monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
le ministre
merci à mme la présidente
je trouvais que les d'abord j'ai dire
que j'ai un avis défavorable possession
je vais oublier vous allez avec raison à
la fin mais je vais te donner quelques
mots d'explication
d'abord j'ai trouvé les arguments du
rapporteur c'est quand même intéressant
parce que effectivement je pense qu'on a
raison vous avez raison monsieur députés
d'être attentif à votre indépendance et
personne ici il se pose la question de
son indépendance
quand il va rejoindre le système
universel de retraite
on pourrait se poser la question de
façon au moins aussi importante pour les
bandes du conseil constitutionnel donc
il faut savoir raison garder
premièrement deuxièmement mois plusieurs
reprises sur le sujet nous c'est moi je
crois les avocats j'ai rencontré le
représentant bien avant d'être au
gouvernement
j'ai pas hésité à dialoguer avec eux
dans une période où c'était déjà pas
facile parce qu'il ne ne percevait pas
l'intérêt d'être dans ce système
universel et donc il ya eu un seul ou
deux séquences de travail que j'ai
évoqué déjà plusieurs reprises depuis
plusieurs mois et moi même j'y ai
participé avec madame la garde des
sceaux est le jeu le premier ministre on
nous avons cherché et nous continuons à
chercher des solutions parce que nous
pensons que les avocats ont une place
importante de notre société et qui
contribuent effectivement la justice au
quotidien
mais tout ça ça peut tout à fait
s'entendre dans le cadre d'un système
universel de retraite c'est pas il n'y a
pas de d'antinomie là dedans
monsieur le député jean pierre vigier
vous avez affirmé il ya quelques
instants que le gouvernement allait
capter les réserves des avocats je suis
désolé je fait c'est faux c'est non
seulement c'est faux non seulement c'est
faux mais vous dispose
si encore vous disposiez d'éléments dans
la loi pour dire cela moi je j'entendrai
votre propos mais là franchement vous ne
pouvez pas donc en fait vous poser une
sorte d'affirmations une contre vérité
que tout le monde peut vérifier
et puis vous allez pouvoir expliquer du
coup avec la même facilité que j'imagine
que toutes les professions libérales
vous ont dit la même chose que
l'agirc-arrco vous l'a dit la même chose
et que en fait toutes les réserves vont
disparaître c'est donc faux c'est donc
faux je suis désolé moi je suis très
attentif à discuter d' éléments de fond
mais pas sur la base d'affirmations
erronées
deuxièmement deuxièmement je pense que
vous avez évoqué le fait que les avocats
et ça a été fait sans doute aussi par
monsieur matin mais le fait que les
avocats et soient attentifs à une forme
de redistribution à l'intérieur leur
profession mais le gouvernement par ma
voix par celle du haut commissaire qui
déjà dans son rapport du 18 juillet le
mentionnait a toujours accepté cette
disposition simplement il faut la
construire avec les avocats et leurs
représentants et voir comment
est ce qu'ils peuvent la financer c'est
ça l'objectif d'ailleurs en fait ça fait
écho à les changes que nous avons eu
assez je crois qualitatif avec monsieur
le député jean-pierre door pour dire
qu'il est tout à fait possible de
trouver des voies de construction avec
les représentants des professions
libérales et moins je crois que nous
allons en trouver très sereinement aussi
avec les avocats à vis des commandes
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur abel
monsieur le président ahmad
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre pourquoi casser ce qui
fonctionne pourquoi remettre en cause un
régime autonome des avocats qui ne coûte
pas un euro d'argent public au
contribuable français
au contraire pourquoi casser un système
qui est juste parce que le revenu
minimum d avocats il est supérieur de
400 euros à celui que vous proposez dans
le régime universel
pourquoi casser un système qui est
efficace parce qu'ils dégagent deux
milliards d'euros de réserves
pourquoi casser un système qui permet à
chacune et à chacun tout simplement de
partir à la retraite au moment où il le
souhaite
il faut vraiment là-dessus ça pas de
sens il faut revenir là-dessus il n'y a
pas d'autre solution que la sortie du
régime universel et c'est le grand
problème de votre projet de loi c'est
que l'universalité est en train de
devenir l'uniformité et elle casse les
spécificités des métiers et prenons
juste un exemple quand vous dites cndf
la caisse est maintenu d'accord mais
elle est maintenue mais à quel prix
quel est le sens d'une caisse quand elle
peut plus lever elle-même les
cotisations honnêtement ça pas de sens
ensuite soumise aux 8 vous inquiétez pas
dormez tranquilles cher ami avocat
on va vous faire un abattement de clg
mais est-ce que vous pouvez ici prendre
l'engagement devant la représentation
nationale que cet abattement il est
constitutionnelle est ce que pouvait
nous garantir que h dans les projets de
loi de finances futur cet abattement ne
sera pas remis en cause
c'est un abattement de papier c'est une
chimère et les avocats l'ont très bien
compris parce que cet abattement il est
anticonstitutionnelle et parce que même
s'il l'était au final il sera remis en
cause dans projet de loi de finances et
enfin quand vous dites on prend pas les
réserves
oui c'est vrai vous piquez pas les
réserves vous fait pire vous les
assécher en leur demandant de financer
une transition dans un régime universel
qui est à la fin
- bon pour eux que ce qu'il était
aujourd'hui donc franchement prenez
raison garder corriger votre système et
maintenez le régime autonome des avocats
je pense que tout le monde
en sortira grandie merci monsieur abad
monsieur vernalis merci madame la
présidente
alors oui dire que la cnbf est maintenu
alors ça c'est vraiment mesquin quoi
parce que dire aux avocats ben vous
allez pouvoir encore quand même gérer
l'administratif de vos dossiers pour
appliquer notre réforme pourri je sais
pas si c'est un gain ou une victoire
quand vous dites on ne touche pas au
fonds de réserve
c'est très juste vous ne touchez pas
formellement vous dit l'avocat notre
réforme est pourri vous allez passer de
14 à 28 % et vous allez vous payer la
vaseline de transition voilà ce que vous
allez faire avec vos réserves
vous allez vous la payez vous même voilà
et ça c'est pas normal ça c'est
scandaleux parce que vous ne donnez pas
finalement de garantie sur le sur le
sujet parce que le sujet de
l'indépendance c'est pas l'indépendance
en soin de gérer sa petite caisse dans
son coin
en faisant cette réforme des retraites
appliquées aux avocats vous remettez en
cause l'économie générale des cabinets
et des petits cabinets et donc de la
profession en tant que tel et de sa
capacité en toute indépendance à dire
oui je veux bien de ce dossier ou non je
n'en veux pas eh oui je peux appliquer
ce tarif là où celui là c'est ça la
réalité
si vous couplez l'ensemble avec
l'article 45 de votre projet de loi de
simplification qui file le travail des
avocats aux assureurs
si vous couplez ça avec vos volontés vos
velléités sur l'aide juridictionnelle de
salariés des avocats pour gérer l'aide
juridictionnelle avec des appels
d'offres sur des goths cabinet et des
avocats qui deviendront eux-mêmes
salariés pauvres parce qu'ils géreront
des pauvres
si vous mettez tout ça ensemble alors
oui ça commence à faire sens sur le fait
que c'est vous qui voulait diminuer le
nombre d'avocats par les propositions
que vous faites
parce que ça ne tient pas la démocratie
démographie d'avocats que vous présentez
dans le conseil d'orientation des
retraites vos chiffres ne tiennent pas
la route
oui on a besoin de davantage d'avocats
on a moins d'avocats par habitant en
france que chez tous les nos voisins
européens et sur la libre le libre choix
de l'avocat
si vous y croyez vraiment vous le mettez
riez dans la constitution ce n'était pas
dans votre réforme constitutionnelle
d'avoir le libre choix de l'avocat
et c'est pourtant le cas dans de
nombreux pays à travers le monde
merci monsieur le député je vous invite
à soyaux oui oui monsieur je vais vous
donner la parole à soigner votre langage
et vos images monsieur le député mais
chez nous bien c'est maintenant la
présidente sur ce sujet là nous avons
déjà eu l'occasion de nous exprimer ce
qui compte je crois c'est pouvoir
anticiper les conséquences de cette
réforme des retraites que vous allez
obliger les français a accepté
en fait les conséquences on l'a déjà vu
en ce qui concerne d un certain nombre
de professions indépendantes dans
d'autres sujets lorsqu'il y a plus de
médecin lorsqu'il ya plus de médecins de
campagne lorsqu'il ya plus de médecins
de famille aujourd'hui les maires élus
locaux s'échinent à trouver des
solutions pour faire revenir des
médecins dans nos villes et bien demain
avec votre réforme il n'y aura plus
d'avocats de proximité et je sais que
nous reviendrons ici un jour déploré les
conséquences de cette réforme en ce qui
concerne les avocats vous êtes en train
d'abîmer l'attractivité de cette
profession l'attractivité de cette
profession elle va jouer évidemment elle
va se concentrer sur des petits avocat
des petits cabinets d'avocats qui font
de l'aide juridictionnelle au quotidien
ce ne sont pas les gros cabinets
d'avocats et vous êtes en fait en train
dubé risée la profession d'avocat vous
êtes en train de paupériser la
profession d'avocat au bénéfice de gros
cabinet d'avocats
alors chers collègues nous nous vous
demandons tout simplement non pas
d'avoir une vision dogmatique sur ce
sujet l'âme cette caisse de retraite des
avocats elle ne pose aucun problème
elle fonctionne n'y touchez pas laisser
les avocats gérer cette caisse eux mêmes
il n'y a aucune garantie d'ailleurs dans
ce que vous proposez aucune garantie sur
l'avenir ne touchait pas à cette caisse
de retraite laisser les avocats la gérer
eux mêmes parce que demain nous
reviendrons ici déploré que vous ayez
tué la profession d'avocat de proximité
merci monsieur chenu monsieur d'or vous
souhaitez faire un rappel au règlement
sur le fondement de l'article article
sont annulés à saint-louis simplement
pour redire que là nous sommes dans la
demande du maintien de caisse autonome
en particulier avocat je vais revenir
une seconde sur problème aussi des
médecins
les météores c'est par rappel au
règlement si c'est déjà la fin le
règlement ben parce que je m'arrête
pas exactement quand il montre tout à
l'heure à ce qu est évident mais
celui-ci simplement monsieur le ministre
le mans une observation
parce que tout à l'heure j'ai été
interpellé
j'ai été interpellé sur le fait que les
médecins à 3 passes et terreur l'a
simplement dire que les caisses des
médecins ont confirmé que jusqu'à 1
passe
leurs pensions été réduite de 30 7% à 2
passes à 32% et à 3 passe de 26 ans
député merci madame avia merci à la
présidente pour revenir donc sur la
question des avocats on a entendu
beaucoup de choses et beaucoup de contre
vérités mais également des éléments des
éléments qui sont vraies est ce que est
ce que la cnbf assure une bonne gestion
de la retraite des avocats
oui c'est pourquoi nous maintenons la
cnbf comme organe de gestion des ddd
retraite des réserves et comme
interlocuteur unique
est ce qu'il y aura une baisse des
pensions non absolument pas et là il
faut absolument rétablir cette
contre-vérité 13% d'augmentation pour le
revenu pour un revenu de 32 32 32 mille
24 % d'augmentation pour un revenu de
40000 11 % d'augmentation lorsque l'on
arrive au dessus donc non il n'y a pas
de baisse des pensions et il faut
arrêter de répéter cela et de aida
chiffres d'agiter un chiffon rouge sur
la question des cotisations sur la
question des cotisations il n'y a pas
d'augmentation des cotisations jusqu'en
2029 et je me permets de rappeler que la
cnds a déjà elle d'ores et déjà voté une
augmentation des cotisations non qu'on
ne passe pas de 14 à 28 il faut revenir
également sur ce qui est prévu
l'abattement de 30% c'est pas juste pour
les avocats c'est pour tous les toutes
les professions libérales et je vous
invite juste à lire l'avis du conseil
d'état
paragraphe 52 vous avez une
interrogation sur son caractère
constitutionnel le conte le conseil
d'état vous dit que c'est cette
interrogation n'a pas lieu d'être et cet
abattement viendra compenser cette
partie kiwi pour les salariés salariés
du privé est prise en charge par les
employeurs
alors la vraie question le vrai sujet
c'est la question des petits cabinets et
de la solidarité qui existe aujourd'hui
dans cette profession entre les gros
cabinets parce qu' on défend revenus et
ceux qui ont des plus faibles revenus
et oui c'est une richesse de la
profession d'avocat et oui c'est un
élément qui je crois doit être maintenu
c'est pourquoi le gouvernement a déposé
un amendement le 21 février je crois que
c'était vendredi d'ailleurs qui permet
de maintenir cette solidarité entre les
cabinets à forts revenus et ceux à
faibles revenus ce qui fait qu'on
maintient ce qui fonctionne bien dans la
profession d'avocat ce qui fait qu'on
maintient ses systèmes de compensation
ce qui fait qu'on reste dans un système
qui reste solidaire ce qui est à
valoriser dans cette profession
alors oui pourquoi changer les choses
pourquoi vous l'indiquez monsieur le
président ahmed
mais maintenir un système qui fonctionne
et bien parce que nous le savons et
toutes les études nous le montre le
système tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui ne
fonctionne plus et ne fonctionnera plus
d'ici quelques années alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait est-ce qu'on détourne le
regard et on attend demain de devoir
réformer la rave plein retrait des
avocats ou est-ce que d'ores et déjà
aujourd'hui on anticipe et on appelle
des solutions mais attention je suis
soulignac
merci madame la présidente nous venons
d'assister à une belle plaidoirie de
maître avia mais je ne suis pas certain
qu'elle puisse convaincre l'ensemble des
avocats de ce pays comme chacune et
chacun d'entre vous peut être je suis
moi même allé à la rencontre des avocats
de mon département qui connaissait ce
texte par coeur qui en mesurent et
qu'ils en avaient apprécié de manière
très fine les risques et j'ai découvert
je le dis ici une réalité de leur métier
que je ne connaissais pas je suis élu
d'un département rural l'ardèche où 70%
des avocats travaillent seuls ils n'ont
pas de cabinet ils n'ont pas d'associé
et ils ont déjà pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux anticiper ce qui va leur
arriver
pour certains c'est rechercher un
travail salarié
pour d'autres c'est se séparer d'un
collaborateur ou d'une secrétaire ou
bien la passer à temps partiel ne
sous-estimez pas ne sous-estimons pas le
mouvement aujourd'hui des avocats qui
sont absolument déterminés et qui sont
également convaincus que la méthode que
vous employez à leur égard s'agissant
d'une caisse qui est équilibré qui n'a
pas besoin de la solidarité nationale
excédentaire qui contribuent au régime
général
ils ne comprennent pas l'autoritarisme
dont vous faites preuve à leur égard
donc puisque c'est à la mode que j'ai
cru comprendre que le gouvernement
maintienne parfois la formule du retrait
provisoire pour les avocats je vous
demande de prononcer ce retrait
provisoire qui vous permettra de
retourner dans des discussions apaisées
avec eux et de trouver une sortie par le
haut je vous remercie
solignac monsieur fuchs merci mme la
présidente
il y à un conflit social avec les
avocats il ya une discussion avec les
avocats une grande partie bien sûr des
avocats discutent avec les
parlementaires avec le gouvernement et
on voit dans cet hémicycle derrière
immédiatement avec beaucoup de démagogie
tous les partis politiques s'engouffrer
dans cette dans cette brèche certains
avec beaucoup d'eux est ce que je peux
attendez je vais voir suivait monsieur à
chaque fois
poursuivez monsieur fuchs c'est mon
point de vue non mais on peut est ce que
je peux est-ce que je peux parler vous
me répondrez si vous le souhaitez vous
avez règlement à votre disposition
prenez le sait ici ce que je dis n'est
pas correct une partie de l'hémicycle
oui mais tant d une partie de
l'hémicycle défend les avocats alors que
dans leurs projets leurs preuves des
premières dispositions c'est de
siphonner l'ensemble des réserves des
avocats donc c'est assez paradoxal
or gouverner gouverner c'est prévoir
1 on a un système par principe universel
dont il n'y a pas de raison de ne pas
intégrer les avocats d'un régime général
de solidarité on l'a vu à 99% de
répartition les avocats avaient une
démographie de 15 actif pour 1 et paul
10 actifs pour un inactif il y a quinze
ans aujourd'hui nous sommes à 4,1 pour 1
que se passera-t-il dans 10 ans ou dans
quinze ans peut-être serons-nous à deux
pour un
peut-être à un pour un nous n'en savent
nous n'en savons rien et donc prévoir
justement gouverner c'est prévoir
nous protégeons les avocats par cette
disposition
nous sommes certains la question
maintenant bien évidemment c'est la
façon dont les négociations vont se
dérouler et là je demande à l'ensemble
des acteurs le gouvernement et les
avocats de revenir à des dispositions de
façon plus constructive
voilà c'est la nature de cette
négociation qu'il faut apaiser mais les
mesures elle-même et on l'a vu
aujourd'hui dans les négociations telles
qu'ils ont lieu avec le gouvernement si
monsieur une telle augmentation entre
aujourd'hui et 2029
donc on parle de quelque chose mais à
négocier entre 2029 et 2040 bien alors
je crains que votre
terme de démagogie n'ait suscité
quelques rappels au règlement monsieur
fuchs donc monsieur le président à bad
oui madame la présidente rappelle
règlement effectivement simplement
monsieur fuchs c'est pas parce qu'on
pense pas comme vous qu'on est dans la
démagogie
moi je respecte votre position je dis
pas que vous êtes d'un démagogue je
respecte vos arguments ce ne sont pas
les miens mais j'aimerais que la
réciproque soit vraie parce qu'a
toujours critiquer les oppositions sur
la démagogie c'est comme ça que vous
créez d'antiparlementarisme et c'est ce
que nous voulons pas et madame la
présidente rappelle règlement aussi sur
l'article 100 parce que monsieur le
ministre il faut vous nous répondit sur
cette question constitutionnelle
vous avez proposé un amendement sur un
abattement nous avons des doutes la
constitutionalité cela est ce que
pouvait aujourd'hui rassurer la
représentation nationale et au delà de
ça vous engager à ce que dans le
prochain projet de loi de finances et
dans les prochain ça sera pas remis en
cause parce que aujourd'hui on a besoin
de ces éléments-là concret parce que
c'est un marché de dupes
et la vérité c'est que finalement c'est
cela qu'il nous faut aujourd'hui il faut
des réponses claires
les avocats nous demande une chose c'est
ne pas rentrer dans ainsi un régime
universel qui ne correspond pas à leur
régime autonome qu'ils avaient
aujourd'hui qui leur permettait tout
simplement d'or au niveau du jeu
rappelle que les avocats ils partent à
la retraite à 65 ans et donc ils ont
aucune leçon à recevoir de personne sur
la contribution au système de la
solidarité assassiné monsieur jumelles
trois rappels au règlement sur quel
fondement sur les fondements de
l'article son alinéa 5 l'opposition
ayant été traités de démagogique et
c'est évidemment pas acceptable
vous oubliez de choses le conseil
national des barreaux continue de dire
que le gouvernement n'apporte aucune
réponse aux droits acquis à la retraite
dans le système actuel par ailleurs
manama via a menti devant la
représentation nationale
lorsqu'on calcule une pension qui
augmente de 13% pour des avocats ayant
gagné 32 mille euros elle oublie de dire
que ce calcul intègre un taux de
cotisation multiplié par deux et donc on
ne peut pas bah oui parce que le conseil
national des barreaux fait cette
démonstration
si le taux de cotisation est multiplié
par deux effectivement les taux de
pensions augmenteront de 13%
mais sauf que vous dites dans le même
mouvement que ce taux ne sera pas
multiplié par deux enfin la
constitutionnalité de la mesure de
compensation
elle nous rend pas seulement dubitatif
nous sommes certains que ça pose la
question de l'égalité devant l'impôt
et que c'est donc en constitutionnel je
le ministre répondait à cette question
bien monsieur berne à lucien rappels au
règlement
merci madame la présidente c'est
identique 58 l'article 100 pour le fait
personnel je voudrais redire un certain
nombre de collègues qui ne savent pas
lire ou qu'ils ne veulent pas comprendre
ce que nous avons écrit dans notre
combat contre projet sur les retraites
il l'est il n'est pas question pour nous
de prendre dans les réserves des avocats
et des autres
nous disons juste que à l'heure où nous
parlons et c'est un constat économique
il y à 150 milliards de réserves dans
diverses caisses y compris pour le
régime général qui permettent de voir
venir la situation pour les années à
venir
les avocats eux-mêmes mettent en réserve
pour pouvoir taper dedans le moment venu
parce qu'ils leur ont décidé et c'est là
le problème c'est que là c'est pas eux
qui vont décider de taper dans leurs
réserves
c'est c'est vous qui les obliger à
prendre dans les réserves pour appliquer
votre réforme pourri c'est de ça dont on
est en train de parler alors vous pouvez
faire semblant de pas savoir lire chers
collègues mais c'est de sa bien monsieur
monsieur bernard sadet mme laprise bis
mais c'est pas vraiment un rappel au
règlement vous rappeler l'article
je vais vous rappeler l'article sens
c'est une mise en cause personnelle
alors c'est alors c'est pas l'article
censé l'article 58 c'est une mise en
cause personne vite et sans à la fois la
bonne tenue de débats est à la fois la
mise en cause personnelle sur notre
contre-projet nom met en corrélation les
fonds sont formels règle madame la
présidente
est ce que vous saviez est ce que vous
saviez que la cnbf la caisse spéciale
les barreaux de france gère aussi leur
action sociale géré l'action sociale des
avocats et que demain avec leur système
ce sera plus possible c'est ça aussi la
vérité de ce qu'ils mettent en place non
mais que les choses soient claires on ne
peut pas utiliser l'article 100 pour
relancer sur le fond les arguments voilà
donc je le rappelle bon monsieur fuchs
vous souhaitez vous
man ray intervenir sur un rappel au
règlement sur quel fondement sur
l'article ça va prendre
sûr qu'elle va en star dont l'article
sans alenia 5 comme comme l'ensemble de
mes collègues
non mais vous allez réintervenir sur le
fond non pas du tout pas du tout bien
éclairer mes propos je n'ai cité
personne j'ai parlé de propos
démagogiques ces personnes si certains
si oui mais je n'ai cité personne j'ai
parlé des propos et si vous sentez visé
vous avez réagi mais je n'ai cité
personne les années c'était je ne mets
groupe
j'ai parlé des propos je vais parler des
gens d'autrefois clair bien bien bien
bien
donc monsieur baignoire merci mme la
présidente
lorsqu on soutient le principe du
système universel de retraite par points
ce qui est mon cas ce qui est quand je
rappelle des centristes depuis plusieurs
législatures moi je ne vois pas
d'obstacle à ce que le système universel
soit élargie à certaines aux professions
libérales qui ont à cette heure en 2020
des caisse autonome bien géré pour des
questions de ressources pour des
questions de démographie
le jour où les ressources et les
démographies auront changé
perpère peut-être que les gérants de ces
caisses autonomes viendront voir le
système universel pour l'intégrer moi je
fais partie de ceux qui veulent
améliorer on en parle depuis une semaine
je veux améliorer les conditions de
retraite des petits exploitants
agricoles des artisans des indépendantes
de celles et ceux qui ont des retraites
modeste et je pense je le pense c'est
pour ça que je le dis que le système
universel va demander des efforts moi je
souhaite qu'il y ait des efforts de
solidarité exercés par des gens qui
aujourd'hui ont de beaux revenus et de
belle retraite et je pense que
d'intégrer certaines professions dans un
système universel vise à amplifier le
phénomène de solidarité par contre et je
termine par là avec notre groupe nous
avons déposé un amendement dit 1916
qui vise à généraliser viendront des
caisses vient de nous aujourd'hui
là c'est un sujet pour assurer la
transition vers le système universel
merci madame dubié oui merci madame la
présidente je pense que le débat que
nous avons autour de la retraite des
habous cas est symptomatique de la façon
dont a été gérée cette réforme des
retraites
et cette accélération depuis le mois de
décembre
je pense vraiment que le pas
suffisamment de temps n'a été pris pour
continuer les négociations que ce soit
d'ailleurs avec les représentants
salariés épreuve année puisque les
négociations se continue en parallèle de
ce qui se passe ici dans l'hémicycle
mais les négociations aussi n'ont pas eu
non pas été suffisamment approfondie
avec l'ensemble parce qu'on parle
beaucoup des avocats mais c'est pas
seulement que les avocats c'est aussi
toutes ces caisses autonomes qui ne
demande rien à la solidarité nationale
qui se sont organisés de façon
corporatistes et qui reconnaissons le
ont aussi ça a été rappelé par notre
collègue bernalicis ont aussi des
systèmes d'action sociale à l'intérieur
de leurs régimes et cette dimension là
n'est pas suffisamment pris en compte et
puis moi je m'inquiète aussi pour des
territoires ruraux pour des territoires
de montagne parce que ce type de
dispositions vont aussi fragiliser la
représentation de ces professions sur
nos territoires et j'ai envie de dire
parce que cette ce proverbe me viennent
à l'esprit à l'instant
qui trop embrasse mal étreint je crois
que c'est effectivement le problème de
cette réforme aujourd'hui si madame
dubié donc nous avons un scrutin public
sur le 24 1779 défendu par me like
huster qui a reçu l'avis défavorable
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos voici le résultat du
scrutin votants 82 exprimé 77 majorité
39 pour 20 contre 57
l'assemblée n'a pas adopté autre scrutin
public sur le vans 4157 est identique
celui qui a été défendu par monsieur
vigier qui a recueilli un avis
défavorable le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votants 77
exprimé 75 majorité 38 pour 20 contre 55
l'assemblée n'a pas adopté pour votre
information chers collègues avant que je
ne suspende depuis le début de l'examen
du texte nous avons examiné 30
amendements à l'heure ce matin nous
avons examiné cinquante deux amendements
à l'heure
donc voilà je le dis pour réflexion
avant la séance de cet après-midi la
séance est suspendue proches élevé
prochaine séance cet après midi à 15
heures suite du projet de loi instituant
un système universel de retraite la
séance est levée